Speaker 1: Let's go next to Jack from
Connecticut. Jack, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Good afternoon,
David. Thank you for having me.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Speaker 2: I watch your content
and it is very informative.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 2: Despite the fact that Donald Trump was,
in my opinion, one of the worst presidents
in American history, he was able to open the
American people's eyes on the importance but also
complicated process of American democracy. And I
just want your opinion. What do you think will be
in the worst case, the best or worst case scenario
in the upcoming 2024 presidential election?
Speaker 1: Well, the worst case is that Trump
or someone even worse, becomes president. And and
we again, have a complete flouting of norms and
and and in many cases, the law. The best case
is that, you know, a better candidate, whether
it's Joe Biden or whoever wins and and continues
putting the country on a slightly better path than
it was headed under Trump. But I don't know that
I agree. You know, when when you said Jack Trump
opened the eyes of Americans to the complexities
of of our democratic process, that's like putting
a really favorable spin on Trump, basically
normalized authoritarianism among a large swath
of American voters. I don't know that it's really
opening the eyes. I think it's I think that's
too positive a spin to put on what Trump did.
Speaker 2: Of course. Absolutely. I I absolutely
hate what he did on January six. I was just
saying that from my perspective, because
I'm a big fan on U.S. history, I was exempt
from the U.S. history final in high school.
There's a lot of things that I did not know
about in the process because it wasn't really
televised as much. The media wasn't paying.
Speaker 1: Oh, Jack, you're saying you're
saying quite literally like you just
learned about the process for like
certifying the electoral votes, like in
the nitty gritty. You're saying you didn't
know about that. You learned about that?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Oh, okay. Okay. And also
the fact that people are paying much more
attention to that now as people as people
have not much has done in previous elections.
Speaker 1: Okay. That's that's fair. That's
fair. I think I thought you were saying something
different. But yeah, I mean, listen, the worst
case scenario for 24 is very bad. So let's work
to prevent it from becoming reality 100%. Yeah.
All right, my friend. Thank you for the call.
Speaker 2: Thank you very much. Much appreciate.
Speaker 1: It. All right. We are taking calls
right now. If you'd like to speak to me,
you can use the raise your hand function, which
is a very, very powerful and important function.